Hey guys, Matt Goodwin here.
Do you want to replace the Conservative Party?
That's the question that I look at in today's sub sec.
And it's based on a remarkable new poll that just came out.
And they asked the British people, firstly,
what do they want to happen at the next general election?
And for a start, only 14%.
So they want the Conservative Party to win that election.
But it also ask them,
do they want the Conservative Party to completely disappear
and be replaced by something altogether new?
Now I'm not gonna give you the figure
of just how many people hold that view.
It's in the sub stack at matt Goodwin dot org.
But it does point to the sheer scale of disillusionment out there
with the Conservative Party,
with the state of the country
and the immense public appetite for something different.
So check it out at matt Goodwin dot org.